VACCINIREMENT FOR ALVE DUTRYWE.
D.
CONFESSIONALTRAVIS COULDIE
AVOIDED VAE AN S
HE
SHOT.
HELS HIMSELF FOR
TRAVIS CHRONICLED HIS BATTLE IN
>>HE COUGH IIT MAKES YOU THINK
TOUT, LOSE
S.
ONFUSED. ]D ASK FOR PRAYERS, F T
ALREADY SET.
>>> COULDN'T MTHE HOSPIT.EY ADM.
IT'S KIND  AA G.TTF
I BELIEVE I'VE GOTTEN HEM GOA G.
-- AND COAGULATING CRYSTAL --
THATAVE GROWN.
--
TONIGHT AND TOMORROW WHEN YOU
THAT ALBUM AND SEEF IT U SAEA
-- A DECISION IF I'M GOING T
O  ON A
VENTILATOR -
AND I DON'T WANT
BUT I WANT TO LIVE.
>>> MADET THROUGH THE NIGHT.
IT WAS A LONG ONE.IGHT I CAM
REALIZATION THAT THE CHANCES OF
ME ABLE TO G
DAHTER AWAY  HER WEDDING IS
THAN WALKING OUT
I HAD TO MAKE A PHONE CALL TO MY
14-YEAR-OLD SON, TO
TELL HIM
MY DRE W GIVING MY DAUGHTER
AWAY AT E ALR, I HAD TO
ASK FOR HIS PERMISSION IF I
DIDN'T COME HOME IF HE WOU
GIVE MY DAUGHTER AWAY ON HER
Y.
>> IT IS, S SO HARD TO W
THAT.
FACING THIS REALITY, BERMA T TH
S REALLY WHAT LS AIF THEY ULIN E
TRAVIS CAMPBELL IS SHOWING
>> TT S DEVASTATING.
THAT WAS JUST DEVASTATING.
IMAGINE CALLING YOURTO TELL HIEE
TO
HOPE HE DOES,ND OESN'T THIN AK
WE APPRECIATE TH INDING.
BUT I'VE GOTE WEHEAR FROM PE IND
SUFFERING COVID,